c---span fans
[Music]
Elayne I'm good evening everybody thank
you all so much for coming out tonight
for this event
I am lissome ask a teen I'm one of the
co-owners of politics and prose my
husband and co-owner business partner
Brad Graham is floating around in the
back somewhere and on behalf of our
terrific staff here we welcome all of
you to to the event tonight a few
housekeeping matters before we get
started I think most of you have been to
events here but for anyone who hasn't
our guests will speak about her book and
then we'll take questions at the end we
do record these events we also have
c-span here tonight if you can possibly
make it to the microphone that is right
here next to this pillar we would be
really grateful because that makes the
audio much more enjoyable for those who
are trying to listen who aren't actually
physically in this space also if you
have a phone or other noise making
device on your person and you could
possibly silence it or make it so that
it won't make noise we'd be grateful for
that
and then lastly at the end of the event
if you wouldn't mind just folding up
your chairs and putting them to the side
Elaine will sign books up here we have
plenty of copies up front I think you
all know what it looks like
and she'd be happy to sign at the end
just up here at the table I also want to
just point out that we are coming to the
end of Women's History Month it's been a
great month for us here at the store
we've had some terrific events I think
for me this one is the highlight we have
a whole table dedicated to books about
women by women related to women's
history it's up toward the front of the
store and we are very very happy to be
able to celebrate this month with such
terrific authors and terrific books with
that I just want to say what a privilege
it is to host Elaine show
at P and P tonight she'll be talking
about her new book I think it's her
tenth book it's called the Civil Wars of
Julia Ward Howe I'm sure many of you saw
that it was the lead review in the
sunday New York Times a few weeks ago so
congratulations on that very well
deserved it was very exciting to see
that and I'll get to the book in the
minute but I wanted to mention that
several of Elaine's family members are
here tonight too and it's it's just
frankly not fair that so much talent
resides in one families gene pool
Elaine's daughter vehicle of Fleurus at
the back she was the one handing out the
beautiful little M&Ms vinca is a friend
and former colleague of mine from the
Clinton White House and I have to say
and she's too humble ever to say this
but she is one of the finest speech
writers in the country was then has been
since still is now her brother and
Elaine's son Michael is not here but you
may know of him he's getting terrific
reviews right now as director of the new
film hello my name is Doris that stars
Sally Field and writer thank you
director and writer Deborah Tannen is
correcting me Thank You Deborah
and lastly always happens at politics
and prose I swear to god somebody always
can knows a little bit more so I'm thank
you for that
and lastly Elaine's husband only English
Showalter is a professor for many years
in scholar I think where did you go oh
there you are over here scholar of 18th
century French who is as devoted a
partner and champion as any spouse could
possibly be the sort of spaced out
spouse sadly that Julia Ward Howe
herself never had but anyway welcome to
all of you family members most of us
know Julia Ward Howe for having written
the Battle Hymn of the Republic
and if we're slightly more studious
students of history we might also know
that she was a poet and later an
abolitionist and advocate for women's
suffrage but we likely don't know the
depths of her misery and marriage her
secret writings or on a brighter note
the company she kept with the cultural
and political elite of her day in this
wonderful biography we become deeply
immersed in her public and private
worlds
and as a title of the book suggests we
become witnesses to her Civil War's her
gallant but often tenuous attempts to
match up her great gifts ambitions and
opinions against the challenges and
expectations placed on women in 19th
century America I just love this book
and I'm not going to be shy about I love
this book and not not simply because
it's a great biography not simply
because it's a great work of historical
scholarship though it is surely both of
those
it's just narrative nonfiction at its
best it's an incredible story a story
that tells a much bigger story and in
such a way that engages the reader so
deeply and on so many levels that if you
pick this book up you will not put it
down and that should be no surprise
given the author Elaine is a professor
emeritus of English at Princeton and the
most respected feminist literary critic
of her generation her previous books all
attest to her profound influence on the
Academy as she's reshaped scholarship
about American women for many
intellectuals that would suffice for
career accomplishments but Elaine is not
any intellectual or any scholar her
daughter vinca told me that she has
never been content to cloister herself
in an ivory tower she is after all at
heart a teacher and luckily for these
four Princeton students several
generations of them have gotten to know
that firsthand and I might also say that
here at P&P we also know this and I
frankly cannot believe that we're so
lucky because Elaine is teaching classes
here now and not surprisingly as one of
our most popular instructors in fact I
just found out a few minutes before the
event started that there are only two
spots left in her upcoming class on
great short stories by American women so
if you have any interest I would suggest
signing up right away and thank you for
for coming and teaching here we really
appreciate it beyond her teaching and
book writing she's an enthusiastic
popular culture she's written TV reviews
for People magazine and she's a regular
on Twitter and she has also confessed in
print to a passion for shopping
describing herself as a woman and a
feminist quote who never saw an earring
I didn't like who has many back copies
of Vogue as Victorian studies whose idea
of bliss is an
afternoon in the makeup department at
Saks so in thinking about her latest
book and why it resonates so deeply with
me and I think with so many others I
think it's because the many parts of
Elaine scholar teacher intellectual
feminist popular culture culture
enthusiasts come together so fully in
her writing and storytelling this is
obviously an important book but more
importantly it's just a marvelous book
thank you so much for being here
[Applause]
that's a most wonderful introduction I
absolutely I love that introduction I'm
going to start out with a bit of what we
know please stand and sing this song
with me
would you please it's the Battle Hymn of
a public um you know the words
[Music]
I have seen the glory
[Music]
vintage where The Grapes of Wrath star
has used his faithful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks to my grandson Jack for setting
that up for me and for all the politics
and prose were all the tech assistance
that's Whitney Houston and it's 1991 in
her performance she was at the Naval Air
Station in Norfolk welcoming home our
troops from the Gulf War and if you see
the video which is on YouTube she is
singing - about 3,000 military personnel
and by the end of this she does a kind
of gospel version and everybody is
rocking out it's really kind of amazing
it's it's my favorite version of the
Battle Hymn and you know everybody has
recorded it Elvis did it Johnny Cash did
it Joan Baez did it and of course the
Mormon Tabernacle Choir that all the
ones that you can imagine this is the
one that I really liked the best I think
it's tremendous and it also kind of
brings together the elements of the
military and the spiritual and the
rousing that I think have made it such a
such a classic lyric well when Julia
Ward was growing up in New York she was
a studious redhead living in Manhattan
just under just slightly over five feet
tall and she dreamed as a teenager of
becoming an important American writer
she says through all those years I had
the vision of some great work which I
myself would give to the world I would
write the novel or the play of the age
now that did not work out first of all
her father who is a very rich banker in
New York he owned what is now half of
midtown Manhattan he censored her
reading affection so she actually read
very very few novels as a girl although
she did sneak off to read your songs she
was not allowed to go to the theater and
when she wrote this she had actually
never seen a play so this kind of vision
of her future was quite unrealistic but
like many gifted young women in the 19th
century she turned to poetry as a safe
outlet a femme
an outlet for a young woman and in fact
her own mother who had died at the age
of 27 also bearing six children as Julia
wood managed within 27 years to publish
a few poems herself in the newspapers
and in the ladies annuals these sort of
fancy volumes that were published every
year for gifts to give women at
Christmas now in the end Julia did
publish several books of poetry and she
even wrote a few extremely unsuccessful
plays but the Battle Hymn of the
Republic of course that was her real
contribution to the literature of the
age and as she knew when she wrote her
memoirs in 1899 I've written one poem
which although composed in the stress
and strain of the Civil War is now sung
south and north by the champions of a
free government okay so one poem out of
the nineteenth century but that's a lot
more than many poets get and certainly
more than most nineteenth-century
American poets got and she deserves her
place in history and her place on the
postage stamp and so on simply for that
over 154 years since she wrote it it's
become a part of not only the American
but the international repertoire of
music about heroism honor justice
mourning certainly spiritual mission it
was performed at the National Cathedral
in Washington after 9/11 and one critic
has said about it that the Battle Hymn
has become the closer it is the music
that accompanies the end of great
American lives it was played at the
funeral of Bobby Kennedy Ronald Reagan
and very recently Nancy Reagan too and
that was really extraordinary I noticed
that because very few women are included
in the list of those who had it played
at their funerals because very few women
have state funerals right you don't
really know about that and in fact
although the battle and was played at
the funeral of Winston Churchill it was
not played for Margaret Thatcher so it's
kind of interesting it is identified I
think with male heroism on the other
hand it has become a kind of a meme you
know kind of a referee for deter
and women and you think of the Battle
Hymn of the tiger mother for example and
there's also the Battle Hymn of Sarah
Palin now if you don't know the Battle
Hymn of Sarah Palin and you have a
couple of three minutes and that you
google it because it is unbelievable
okay and of course it's also inspired
the titles of a number of great American
novels most famously John Steinbeck's
The Grapes of Wrath
she wrote it in Washington probably all
know the legend
she wrote it in November 1861 she had
come on a trip to Washington with her
husband dr. Samuel Gridley Howe I'll be
saying a bit about him later and some
friends from Boston and that winter they
were staying in the Willard hotel
incidentally which has a plaque for
Julia we're home
that winter she sent it to the Atlantic
Monthly and in February 1862 the
Atlantic Monthly printed it on the cover
and they paid her five dollars within a
short time it was the anthem of the
Union armies and in 1864 it was
performed before President Lincoln and
then in December 2012 the original
manuscript of the song signed by Howe
this is the script she had written out
in the Willard hotel was optioned by
Christie's for seven hundred and eighty
two thousand dollars so it's quite an
appreciation over time I don't know who
bought it maybe somebody will find out
I'd love to know who bought it because
he doesn't say but Malcolm Forbes was
the one who sold it now Julia Ward Howe
story is not a new one and in fact the
first biography of Julia Ward Howe was
published exactly a century ago in March
1916 and that was very much in my mind
in writing this book I wanted it to come
out at the centenary to mark a hundred
years of that biography it was in two
volumes it's really a big book and it
was written by her three daughters and I
am pretty sure I can't guarantee but I'm
pretty sure that it was the first
substantial biography of an American
woman before the 20th century
biographies of women
our collective you'd get a big volume in
it would say celebrated women of
Maryland or great women of the American
Revolution that kind of thing but a
biography of one woman two volumes long
that was really remarkable and a year
after it came out in 1917 it won the
first Pulitzer Prize for biography and
that was in fact the first year that the
Pulitzer Prizes were given so was the
first prize for a biography I'm
virtually the first one that was given
for biography in English when it was
done
Columbia University was running the
awards excuse me minute and Nicholas
Butler who was the president of Columbia
said that it was the best American
biography teaching patriotic and
unselfish service to the people so
unselfish this is not the term that we
would ordinarily use to describe our
great American heroes and we don't think
JFK the unselfish president it's not you
know what we're looking to reward and
the house daughters definitely edited
the story of their mother's life to
smooth over any selfish moments and
particularly they presented their
parents turbulent marriage as the union
of two noble souls on the other hand
this by Agra it's not as dull it's not
as didactic as you might think from that
description it's actually pretty
sparkling because it is very hard to
make Julia Ward Howe sound dull and in
fact when it came out apart from the
here we go apart from the pulitzer prize
a critic in the north american review
was kind of puzzled by the biography
because he said he'd never he couldn't
quite get that a portrait of such a
distinguished American a distinguished
woman somehow failed to develop that
unity that
epic quality which distinguished the
greatest biographies and I think by
unity he meant a consistent personality
of the central figure and Julia's
personality as you've heard a little bit
felissa was not totally consistent with
what people thought of as heroic the
reviewer went on to say her life is a
blending of saintliness and friskiness
the steady love of virtue and the
recurrent fondness for jewelry the deep
intellectual interests and the capacity
for joyous nonsense Julia loved shopping
and fashion and parties you get why I
was very attracted to her as a subject
for a biography now shaping the lives of
women who lived a kind of public life to
display epic qualities was a real
challenge for the 20th century and it
wasn't until 1989 that another biography
of a woman by a woman won the Pulitzer
Prize her biography took a long while
for another one to turn up in the middle
of the century how mostly appeared in a
series of popular books about the
childhoods of famous Americans some of
you may remember this from your
childhood they had orange covers they
were in the libraries and sort of all
lined up and Julia appeared as a girl of
old New York in a story that was mostly
invented but but very inspiring in the
1940s she was also hailed in the Wonder
Woman comics as a 19th century Amazon
figure and finally in 1979
Deborah Clifford was a Vermont historian
was a distant relative of the family
published the first modern biography
mine eyes have seen the glory Clifford
was the first one who had looked at the
how family archives which were at the
Houghton library at Harvard and they are
massive I mean they are huge and she was
the first scholar to look at them and
she revealed some of the facts about
this really disastrous marriage and then
in the 1970s the whole concept of
women's biography changed as the women's
movement developed and Carolyn hi
and a book that she wrote called writing
a woman's life posed a whole lot of
questions she said this very little
sense of what a woman's biography should
look like where do you begin do you
begin with her disappointment that she
was not a boy
how does she cope with the fact that her
value is determined by how attractive
men find her if she marries does the
marriage fail or succeed and what does a
successful marriage look like from a
woman's point of view so what I wanted
to do with this book was to bring Julia
Ward Howe alive for a new generation of
readers and I wanted to consider these
questions and also to embrace the
contradictions that made her both
saintly and frisky and I especially
wanted to think about her marriage as a
domestic civil war a battle for
imaginative dominance going on between
two strong people and in my pattern
about her life she was fighting for her
independence from the bonds of matrimony
at the same time that she was fighting
slavery and her liberation coincided
with the end of the Civil War
now something a little bit about the
marriage she married dr. Samuel Gridley
how when she was 22 and it seemed like
the ideal match he was said to be the
handsomest man in Boston he was a foot
taller than she was he was 18 years
older and after medical school he had
followed his hero the poet Byron sorry
I'm going to have to cough again I had a
terrible cold all week
he had followed byron to grease and he
became a hero of the Greek revolution
for independence against the Turks in
the 1830s he went back to Boston and he
immediately became the first director of
the Perkins institution for the blind
and a world-famous pioneer of Education
for the blind and deaf and later he
became really a champion in the
abolitionist movement and a real
activist but unfortunately although he
was a champion of the oppressed in every
area from the handicapped to the slave
Chev which is what she called them after
the after he came back from greece the
king of greece and it's ironic that
after this six years of revolution
greece ended up with a prussian king the
King bestowed upon him an honorary title
the Chevalier descents of war so she
always called him Chev and his friends
called him chef he insisted that married
men should be totally fulfilled by their
homes and children and they should not
speak in public he was a chef was really
quite a brilliant man really remarkable
man in many ways but he was a very
difficult husband he decided where they
would live and he often especially when
he wanted to punish her said they had to
live in the Perkins institution which
was a big drafty marble former hotel in
South Boston two miles from the center
of the city he took control of her
income from her brother and uncles and
he lost almost all of it in real estate
speculation and most seriously for her
he forbid her to publish her poetry or
to teach or to lecture or to preach or
otherwise to act in the public sphere it
was his idea to have six children and he
would have insisted on eight children
except that their youngest son died and
broke their heart so he decided to stop
at sex now Chev was a bossy man he was a
driven man is a very strange man in many
ways and he makes a wonderful villain
and one of my challenges in writing the
book was to try to imagine the marriage
from his perspective I didn't
want to make him just the classic
villain and this really is a challenge
for a biographer because Julia was very
close to her two sisters and in Louisa
and she wrote to them enormous letters
about her family what was going on in
the marriage cheb had several very close
male friends especially charles sumner
who famously was beaten up on the floor
of the senate but he did not discuss his
marriage with them except in very broke
romantic kind of generic terms and
really don't know too much in his words
about what was going on and I was
talking last week in a Boston bookstore
about this and I met for the first time
Jim Trent who is the biographer of chef
Samuel Gridley house biographer it was
really interesting to me that we were
not like attorneys in a divorce case I
have to tell you that I have learned an
awful lot from his biography if Sheva is
a terrific book but it was interesting
as the biographer of the wife to meet
the biographer of the husband and I
noticed a couple of differences between
us first of all in the life story of a
prominent man
the wife often plays a very small part
and there are only a handful of
references to Julia in Jim Trent's
biography of chef on the other hand the
husband of a prominent woman is central
to her life story and I wrote a lot
about him in my book and the second
difference I noted is that Jim's
biography is called the manliest man
which is what chef how chef was
described by his friends this gives you
an idea what he must have been like the
way he was seen by his contemporaries
and it was the way he saw himself and
for a while I thought about calling my
biography the woman least women but I
gave up on that idea pre-cast because
first of all I think that's a very
diminishing epithet for a woman it
doesn't have the same valiance as
manliest man and really Julia did not
see herself as a paragon of femininity
at all and in fact as a child an
adolescent just as Carolyn Auburn said
she often wished that she had been a boy
she was very envious of her brothers and
in the first decade of her marriage she
actually tried to write a book about a
creature of both
sexes who experiences life as a man and
as a woman this extraordinary manuscript
which he never showed to anyone is at
the Houghton library at Harvard and we
know about it because of the heroic
scholarship of a small number of house
specialists by mainly Gary Williams who
edited it and published it as the
hermaphrodite Gary you hear there's Gary
Gary okay Gary Williams is the first
house caller I ever met we met in London
some years ago and he's one of the most
generous and I'm delighted he here
tonight this is this is the book the
hermaphrodite is published by the
University of Nebraska Press it has a
very sexy cover and we really owe
everything we know about it to Gary and
in thinking about the marriage of the
house
I was also influenced by a wonderful
book called parallel lives by Phyllis
Rose which some of you may know which
looked at the political dynamics of five
Victorian marriages Rose argues that
marriage is a political negotiation it's
a story with two points of view often
deeply in conflict sometimes luckily
congruent and I tried to see the house
as writing and living two separate and
parallel stories and try as best I could
to figure what was going on in chef's
head at the time that Julia was writing
to her sisters now he held most of the
cards but Julia and I wanted to be clear
about this she's not totally a victim
she was capable of fighting back and in
fact a woman who can write always has a
weapon against a domineering husband her
first book of poems passion flowers I
think of both as her personal battle
hymn and as a revenge book like Nora
Ephron's heartburn if you know that book
she wrote after her split from Carl
Bernstein so I want to read a teeny
little book for my book this is about
Julia when she was working on passion
flowers in the fall of 1853
she had decided to write this book with
the advice of Longfellow who was one of
chefs best friends who also kept it a
secret and many of the poems were about
the marriage and they were very strong
so all that fall she was thinking that
she was going to keep it a secret from
chef she was not going to tell him that
she was writing this book and not
publishing it as she wrote to Annie I
have a great mind to keep the whole
matter entirely from him and not let him
know anything until the morning the
volume comes out then he can do nothing
to prevent it sail in its proper form
dear Annie could one do this he has
known all summer that I intended
publishing and has made no objection and
not much comment now chef of course
disapproved of women publishing married
women publishing and he had the power to
prevent her for making a work public but
she also knew he had little sympathy
with poetry every now and then
Longfellow would bring him a signed book
and chef would kind of make a polite nod
and put it away somewhere and she
thought that he'd really didn't
understand poetry and he would not get
what the poems were about so his lack of
interest made her feel that was safer to
go ahead was publication in any case it
was very important for her pride not to
seek his permission to write her to
publish towards the end of December the
proofs arrived and checking them was
unexpectedly taxing she complained to
Annie about it the endless endless
plague of looking over these proof
sheets the doubts about phrases rhymes
and expressions tomorrow I get my last
proofs then a fortnight must be allowed
for drying and binding then I shall be
out fairly out do you hear so far my
secret has been pretty well kept my book
is to bear a simple title passion
flowers without my name according to
longfellows advice Longfellow has been
reading a part of the volume he says it
will make a sensation chef knows nothing
as yet
I feel much excited it's quite unsettled
even a little frantic if I succeed I
feel [ __ ] I shall be humbled by my
happiness now I will not write anymore
about it well that was some Christmas at
the house passion-flowers changed the
balance of power in the house in both
directions really and it changed Julia's
ideas about her own emancipation do you
want to know what happened I tell this
whole story in the book but it was it
was pretty intense and then the Civil
War also changed nineteenth-century
ideals of the separate spheres of men
and women
it changed assumptions about gender as
well as race and it propelled women out
of domestic confinement into public
lives and careers and at the end of the
Civil War in 1865 Julia made up her mind
she would no longer fall a worship plate
behind Chev but that she would dedicate
her life as he had dedicated his to the
highest needs of humanity the needs she
saw and valued according to the
convictions of her heart
in fact on their 22nd anniversary in
1865 she decided to go and speak to the
women prisoners at the Salem
penitentiary instead of celebrating the
event so pretty strong gesture as she
approached her 50th birthday in 1869 she
had a vision of a new world of womanhood
during the first two-thirds of my life
she recalled I looked to the masculine
ideal of character as the only true one
and in an unexpected hour a new light
came to me the world of womanhood this
discovery was like the addition of a new
continent to the map of the world her
true mission became women's suffrage she
went on the road with the suffragists
she never stopped traveling writing
speaking and working for women's rights
in her pretty lace caps designed by one
of her son and laws she became known as
the dearest old lady in America but that
was not how Julia saw herself at all she
refused to be stuck in the 19th century
on her 91st birthday she told an
interviewer that her advice to American
women was be up to date that's on the
MMS I think maybe she took her revelry
she was up to date herself she took very
readily to the telephone the typewriter
the phonograph the automobile and
especially the elevator including when
the children had installed in her house
so that she could send divinely to the
upper stories she entertained Oscar
Wilde
to the horror of the Boston Brahmins who
actually wrote about it in the newspaper
she wrote back I will have to dinner
anyone I like and he's a very clever
young man she took two walks a day until
she was 91
she ate what she damn pleased including
fried foods mince pie and champagne and
two weeks before she died she went off
to get an honorary degree from Smith of
course there as everywhere she went they
sang the Battle Hymn of the Republic
Julia Ward Howe never achieved the level
of unity of relentless cheerfulness
unselfishness piety and austerity that
society still demands from its female
worthies she remained an unsettling
mixture of saintliness and friskiness
but she didn't mind as she declared I do
not desire ecstatic disembodied
sainthood I do not wish to abdicate any
one of the attributes of my humanity
I cherish even the infirmities that bind
me to my kind I would be human an
American and a woman these are words I
think for a biographer to live by and
glory glory hallelujah for that
if anybody has questions I'd love to
hear them and if you could make your way
to a mic that would be great if you're
strapped in the middle I can hand you
this mic how long did she live after her
husband died he was 18 years older you
said yeah he was 18 years old he died in
1876 they were married for 33 years and
she lived 34 years after his death and
how did her life change it changed quite
tremendously one of the first things
that happened while he was dying they
had what seemed like a reconciliation
and she says in her journals she said I
had my double bed moved into his room
they had had separate rooms sir I don't
know how long that had them a long time
she moved the double bed in the room
with his double bed and in the last few
days they shared confidences and she
thought it was wonderful ending but a
few days after he died they read the
well and he had left her nothing in the
wealth and not only did he leave her
nothing in the well but he said in the
well to Julia I to my wife I leave
nothing because she is so capable of
taking care of herself and of course he
had spent all of her inheritance I mean
she came to him she had she had
inherited a sex of this fortune of the
father who owned all of midtown
Manhattan so when he married her she was
really an heiress a tremendous amount of
money and property and he he lost it all
nothing so she had tiny tiny little
income left and basically from the
moment he died she had to support
herself pretty much till the end of her
life eventually her son helped out and
her daughters helped us so she was not
only on the road for women suffered she
lectured everywhere she gave lectures
for money she wrote for money and you
didn't get much money for either
lecturing or writing at that times it
she's pretty active on the other hand
she liked us you know she was enabled to
do things that she had always dreamed of
being in some ways and we used to say in
the women's movement she became
that she had married I mean gonna put
another way she you marry the man that
you want to be something like this and
after chefs death in a way she became a
public figure as he had been he was a
famous speaker and traveler and lecturer
so she in some ways took his life on she
was very happy those last year she
traveled all over the world traveling is
incredible in in the age before Jets I
mean doing this on steam ships
everywhere she went around the world
twice she went she went to England I you
know like we go to New York so pretty
amazing thanks to the question hi I am
really looking forward to reading your
book because I knew very little about
her and I just kind of glanced I'm
italian-american but so I found that you
had something on Italian immigrants that
aside from being a suffragette and an
abolitionist that she on page 236 she
said she became involved with new social
issues including the abolition of the
death penalty the protection of Italian
immigrants Indian Affairs the
Pennsylvania coal miners strike and the
rebellion of the emini ins against the
Turks so how did she I mean she took
these positions but how white I mean did
she did she take these positions and
publicize them through writings anyone
listen to her yes yeah they did I mean
especially in Boston where she became
really a great figure great public
citizen and mostly towards the end of
her life she wrote a loss she traveled
very very late in her life she was
making national tours you do a lot of
speaking on the west coast and she used
to go to the Massachusetts State House
regularly whenever the legislature was
in session she would go and address them
so she did it that way she was very busy
she opposed lynching I mean she she
really was committed to just about all
the social issues of the the turn of the
century and they were a lot and my
second question since no one's behind me
is did you access that what was it
called the Houghton Houghton materials
at Harvard for this book yeah you did
I did but not all of them
I could not have done it I could not
have done it except that many other
scholars had been there by that time
before me and written about it and
published some of them I mean it is
enormous really I mean I don't know how
long it would take any single scholar no
matter how dedicated to read it is so
vast because the whole family was a very
big family it's the whole family samuel
is in it to all the sisters and brothers
and aunts and relatives and everybody so
it's it's huge but I did read it and and
of course she had terrible handwriting I
mean state Stacy chef such a great
biographer she says there are a couple
of things that you should keep in mind
when you decide whose biography to write
in the first is did they win the
penmanship prize and Julia did not when
the penmanship prize let me tell you so
that was my big mistake but I did look
at them and my husband came with me I
couldn't have done it without him and we
sat in the Houghton library and I read
Julia and he read Chev and then we
really kind of trade things back and
forth that was kind of fun did she
adhere to any particular religion yes
she was she she went through several she
was very very very interested in
religion I would say more than being
devoutly religious she was very
interested in theology it was a lifelong
fascination of hers she was brought up
in the Calvinist household and she
really rebelled against that but her
salvation was that she came of age
during the great age of
transcendentalism she knew the
transcendentalists through a friend and
she very quickly through them became
interested in the Unitarian Church and
she was really a Unitarian for most of
her life but she read widely in all
religious traditions she says that the
the reason for her conversion as she was
reading something I think it's in an
essay of Goethe and she said she was
suddenly struck by the fact that the god
she was worshiping must be the same as
the god of the Japanese
and this was a sort of cultural
religious comparison she had never
thought of that before when that idea
hit her her whole idea of religion
changed but she she she peach she
preached often to especially when she
was traveling and she traveled a lot in
Central America and the Caribbean and
when she was there she would often take
the opportunity to preach in a local
church
so her religious writings are extensive
but I I didn't really deal with them in
this book feeling just following up on
that though there's a I'm over here yeah
I had forgotten this until you just
started talking about it but she there's
this interesting little mention in the
book of her when she's in Rome yeah of
studying or meeting with a rabbi you're
learning Hebrew yeah she sort of was
interesting I thought yeah she was she
was a great linguist she learned Greek
when she was 15 she that was most fun I
mean her idea of a real really great
afternoon was to read Greek and she knew
six languages and when she was in Rome
she found a rabbi in the ghetto she says
he was in the ghetto this was in the
1850s and he came to tutor her in Hebrew
very remarkable so she was very
interested in religion generally she was
not at all anti-semitic every trace of
it she on the other hand spent quite a
lot of time in Rome and she really did
not like the Catholic Church did not
like what she saw of it and it was not a
particularly good period if the Catholic
Church just after that and just after
the revolutions the failed revolutions
in Italy so she's extremely cynical
about that but everywhere she went
she was fascinated and she traveled a
lot in the middle heath middle east she
went to harems she was very interested
in Islam
everything was sort of intellectually
fascinating to her you have to read the
book though to know what else she found
in Rome thank you yeah
did she have any interactions at all
with Emily Dickinson
none as far as I can tell she never read
a word by Emily Dickinson but you know
Emily Dickinson's only published seven
poems during her lifetime
Emily Dickinson's poems were not
published until very close to the end of
the nineteenth century and as far as I
can tell Julia never read any of them
she did read Whitman which is
interesting to me because she was
exactly the same age as Whitman and in
the book I talk about the the way that
the odds were so much against a
nineteenth-century American woman poet
she's the same age as Whitman they both
grew up in New York at the same age as
teenagers he was running around the city
totally free
he says going to the theater every day
and every night taking everything that
she was not allowed out of the house
without enormous number of chaperones
and she was not even allowed to go to
this year it's so different I mean the
range of experience that he was able to
draw on well when she finally read
Whitman towards the end of the end of
the nineteenth century she got
interested in reading the wise she she
didn't like him very much
she did read some more experimental
European poetry at the end of her life
and she took to that I don't know what
she would have made of Emily Dickinson
fascinating to think of it Emily
Dickinson is the one really important
woman American woman poet of the
nineteenth century as Whitman I think is
the one really important male poet of
the nineteenth century
not a good century for poetry because
they were so restricted by piety and by
their sense the poetry was a very
serious business and you had to use a
certain kind of vocabulary and she uses
often folk a girl like f soothes and you
know that kind of thing
methinks that nobody ever nobody ever
talks it she wrote she could write in
the vernacular her best poems are like
that and the Battle Hymn I think one of
the reasons it's such a good poem is
that partly because she was writing to
music the rhythm forced her to use them
more forthright direct vocabulary it's
much more emphatic and the only real
archaism in the Battle Hymn is mine eyes
at the beginning and that's biblical
there's a lot of difficult language but
it isn't the kind of a weird kind of
semi medieval ism and some of her other
things and if she had read Dickinson so
direct and vernacular I mean it would
have totally changed it's one of those
things you only wish it could have
happened but no how did her children
view her and how did she view her
children she she really adored her
children and they adored her she had not
planned to have six children and she's
pretty outspoken about this to her
sisters every pregnancy when she finds
out she's pregnant is disaster and she
has names for the children while she's
pregnant you know she's this I'll call
this one Dolores and stuff like that you
know but when they were born she adored
them of course and they adored her and
they said she was absolutely wonderful
mother very playful very imaginative
very engaged in all their games and he
was - he was a good they were good
parents and they made a good parenting
team so when the children grew up and
they wrote the biography and they
actually read her Diaries and they read
the letters and they found out what she
said it was they couldn't really believe
it they had to smooth it out in the
biography but they really didn't believe
it anyway they had their own image and
they said this couldn't have been true
they really adored each other that it
was maybe a little you know little
trouble here and there they said it was
it was the marriage of the torrent and
the wind - very turbulent people but
they really adored each other
interestingly they grew up one of the
sons died as an as a young child one of
the daughters died so she had three
surviving daughters and one son and the
son became a very distinguished
scientist well when they grew up
it was the daughter she was closest to
the son
in some ways is really a lot like chef I
mean I don't know if he was like chef
himself but he had a career a lot like
chefs and he was always getting honors
from international bodies and something
but he was their relationship was
nervous cause very very close to the
daughters and the daughters were all
writers and I think wonderful writers
Laura the oldest wrote 90 books it's
amazing in those days they could really
turn in a Florence the second one not as
much which is quite prolific and I think
very entertaining writer and Maude the
youngest one also wrote a number of
books they always look down on Maude
because they thought she was spoiled and
frivolous the other ones dead but I
liked her very much and eventually she
became an art historian and moved to
Newport which is quite a revered citizen
in the town here yeah
you said that her plays were disasters
yes was that deservedly so
or was she ahead of her time or was the
subject-matter not one that went well
yeah it's interesting I mean I don't
think the plays are that good but I'm
not sure they were ahead of their time
but they were certainly they were in two
categories some of them were just so
cerebral you couldn't imagine making a
play out of them when she was a young
girl she was trying to make a play out
of rise and follow the roman empire
stuff like that she she did write a play
after passion-flowers came out during a
period where in principle she was not
supposed to publish anything but she did
she just there damned if I if I'll do
that and she wrote this play which was
actually produced in New York which was
a kind of melodrama set in Italy and I
have to say I've blocked the title of it
right now
but it opened in New York and it ran for
about a week the New York critics just
hated it and they thought it was both
scandalous and kind of incoherent there
are scholars now who kind of disagree
and think it's actually an interesting
play her brother Sam Ward who was a
lobbyist and a great ball vivan
Washington with the king of the lobby
they called him almost invented Lobby he
was her greatest support he thought was
terrific but not very many other people
did and then she was trying to write a
play about Hippolytus and fedra and that
was a place she worked on for a long
time and her dream was to have edwin
booth play Hippolytus and then there was
of course the assassination and this is
an another incredible thing they were
very close friends of Edwin Booth who
lived in Boston and they went to almost
all his performances and when they found
out that John Wilkes Booth's had killed
Lincoln I mean the whole of boss they
were in double mourning the whole town
was in collapsed and Edwin Booth stayed
off the stage for a
time and that kind of fell apart
how many of her works either either at
plays or poetry had her name on it at
the time of their publication right oh
that's an interesting question let's see
I think by the end of her life probably
several did because a lot of them were
reprints and it was so to be collected
poems and so on in the early part of her
life
the first two were anonymous and then
they would be published you know by the
author of sort of thing but by the end
of her life they did have her name on
them and sadly and I think inevitably
the poetry really declined towards the
end because after passion-flowers Chev
really cracked down and any kind of
growth that she was developing as a poet
and I think she was basically really
talented and gifted as a poet but I
don't think she had any chance to
develop that gift he really cracked down
in terms of subject matter and she
really didn't know any poets I mean if
she known Emily Dickinson you imagine
what might have happened the poets that
she knew Longfellow
Whittier who were friends of theirs in
Boston were very genteel poets nobody
really reads them anymore either she
didn't know anyone who was really
challenging her and she certainly didn't
know any other women who were writing
poetry and by the end of her life these
books were coming out with her name on
them and they were still getting
reviewed but even the critics were
saying she has become the one review I
just read she's become the average poet
s someone who started out was incredibly
unconventional and exciting and new it's
it's not there anymore but I think what
also happened is that when after the end
of the Civil War she decided she was
going to go out and have a public life
poetry became less interesting to her
the lot of women in the 19th century
both in England and America and probably
other places too turned to writing
sometimes fiction sometimes poetry
because
they were barred from all the other
professions I mean I think Julia Ward
Howe would have made a great professor
she was so intellectual she would have
been great you know professor at Harvard
something like that course that was
totally impossible in fact Harvard
didn't hire didn't give women tenure and
the faculty in 1970 something like that
so that was out she knew a lawyer a
politician anything like that a minister
which he was very attracted to none of
those things were open to her so poetry
was the channel into which they poured
all of their creativity and anger and
protest and and intellect and I think
she herself realized in fact she says it
at a certain point I'm never gonna be a
great poet this is not the way I am
going to fulfill myself but I think I'm
a good speaker and she went on the road
and she worked very hard that she said
she studied she got the other
suffragists to teach her how to talk to
a room of angry people which he
encountered very often how did how to
deal with rough necks you know insulting
them and throwing things at them you
know all this kind of stuff she really
studied how to do it she got very good
at it as a speaker and that was really
fulfilling for her so the end of her
life I think she felt she had really
found her rotation in doing that and she
never stopped and the poetry really
trailed off she continued to write comic
poetry and I think some of it is really
very funny but none of those were
published during her lifetime there
wasn't this suspicion that you know
everything a wide suspicion that she was
the author that people just didn't know
who wrote these know what they did or
passionless I should have said that yeah
the book came out I mean I talked about
it here it kept it was published
anonymously but it was Boston Boston was
a pretty small town everybody knew like
in a week who it was so all these
whispers run around and she told Chev
and there's no record in her letters or
heads of that conversation which must
have been really something but everybody
in Boston knew and created an incredible
sensation and some people were very
shocked and horrified
Hawthorne who was in England at the time
he was a console in Liverpool but he got
the book from his publisher who sent it
over to him and Hawthorne said I think
it's one of the most outstanding
American books of the time he said it
along with Walden
Thoreau's Walden this is one of the two
books I would recommend to somebody
wanting to read American literature he
said but she should be whipped for
writing it and that was kind of the
general opinion and you know so it was
it was really scandalous thing and
particularly women she knew and her
women friends were very hostile to it to
the other questions one more question
here you go you've talked a lot about
her closeness and her writing to her
sisters could you just say a few things
quickly about her more intimate circle
of female friendships well that is
really interesting too you know when she
was growing up she didn't have any
really close female friends until she
was almost 20 years old that was because
her father who was very much of a strict
Calvinist he felt that society was a
temptation to sin and since they had so
many brothers and sisters and cousins
they should only mix within the family
and they lived in a kind of family
compound in New York on Bond Street and
house they lived in eventually with
soltan became Brooks Brothers which I
thought was very appropriate they lived
in a fabulous mansion she grew up there
but she never she was not able to mix
with other girls
socially and she never knew any other
young women she felt as a great loss and
then in her 20s after her father died
she made her first woman friend who was
remained her from being married Mary
Grey who remained her friend for the
rest of her life and who lived in Boston
and they met in Newport in the summer
and
was a tremendous boon to her
they shared so much and it was a Mary
Boone who introduced her to the Mary
Grey who introduced you to the
transcendentalists and to the Unitarian
Church and who supported her at every
juncture in her life so that was really
tremendous she really didn't have that
many close friends you know al had a lot
of women friends in Boston they were not
very close
she found Boston very chilly town
socially as I guess other people have
done too but once she got into the
suffrage movement one of the reasons she
took to it so much is that the
suffragists were so sisterly you know
her own sisters one move to Rome one
married and moved to Rome and the other
lived in New Jersey and then in
California and they were her closest
companions which she was young but not
until the suffrage movement did she
really have intimate women friends and
particularly Mary Livermore who was her
closest friend with the suffragists and
who who was very warm and motherly and
she just talks about how they traveled
together and how how wonderful it was to
her how enriching how enabling how much
fun how terrific you know no matter how
bad the weather and how rude the
audience and how terrible the food
whatever it was being traveling with
with Mary Livermore made it okay
we have time for one more question and
if there's no takers I'll ask it but I'm
happy to have somebody from the audience
raised a hand feel like an auctioneer
going going my question and I again I
don't want to give away too much of the
book because there's so many nuances and
intricacies of the relationships in this
book which is one of the things I love
so much about it but the relationship
between her and Chev and this sort of
repressed sexuality and romance that you
feel is part of the source of tension
between them and I'm just wondering if
you would dare speculate what if they
lived in a more tolerant time where they
could sort of be who they really were
who would they have
exactly I mean I think I think the ideal
model would have it Elizabeth Barrett
Browning and Robert Browning who she
knew and she was very she offended yeah
and she was very jealous of both of them
and I think that was the model for her
she knew a lot of women in Boston who in
principle had very companion at
marriages but as it turned out I don't
know how much he knew at the time none
of them did she thought they did Lucy
stone for example she thought oh that's
a wonderful marriage it was not such a
great marriage
but the Browning's really had the
marriage that she want and he totally
supported her and that was very romantic
and he was very handsome and you know it
seemed like like the perfect match it
could have been it could have been very
interesting he was certainly the most
exciting man who came across her path I
think at that time in her life she
waited until she was 22 to marry which
was quite old for that period and he was
definitely the most suitable person that
she met they should have been perfect
and the beginning of the honeymoon
although they were on a steamship going
to ink sounded like it was started
pretty well but it just didn't and I and
I think it has to be blamed mainly on
him I think she was so much younger she
was so inexperienced in certain ways and
he was such a workaholic and then she
started having all these babies so it
was impossible really to know but
potentially what could have been between
them is there and it's electric and it's
one of those things you imagine you know
a parallel life another place another
time what they could have been they
should have been one of the great
romantic couples of of history but I
mean he you know there was a reason he
was still a bachelor at 42 right well I
mean no he goes off to Greece and he's
not really you know he's got other
interests speculation there's a lot of
speculation about show sexuality yeah he
was he was very attached
his male friends and notably
uninterested in women and and he had a
lot of journals he he was in Greece for
six years and passed up all the
temptations are pretty much all of them
was not even interested particularly and
there's some speculation that he was
really most of his sexual and emotional
feelings were directed towards men and
especially Charles Sumner
and Gary has written about this but it's
hard to be to be sure it's hard to be
sure certainly I mean I think myself
we've talked about this I think Charles
Sumner was much more likely to have been
gay Sumner they used to say about summer
he didn't get married until he was one
in his 50s or something and they used to
say but Sumner he isn't gonna get
married because he doesn't want make any
woman a slave or something like this you
know but he he just was shearing away
from it as hard as he could and his
marriage lasted a very short time his
wife ran off with somebody else but chef
I think was at least a bisexual if
anything but in that age they didn't
really deal with these feelings of these
issues and of course they had a lot more
leeway to express themselves so his
letters to Sumner
are very passionate and emotional and
intimate and and they were very very
close and he doesn't write like that to
Julia at all it's not there for women
for him but I don't think he was
incapable of it towards the end of his
life when they had this reconciliation
people think that he told her he had
been having affairs and I'm not sure
about that either I mean it sounds like
he did and you don't really know it
would be interesting you know the
letters were all destroyed so you don't
really know what happened if they were
affairs I think they must have been
pretty limited I don't think he was the
kind of man to do that he was certainly
his sexuality I think I went into his
work Mesa mainly so I think you can tell
from the last hour the
the this is a incredibly fascinating
story very fascinating woman and very
fascinating people around her as I said
we have copies of the book upfront if
you haven't had a chance to get it
please do Elaine will be happy to sign
up here thank you so much what a great
thank you discussion and thank you all
for coming out today and if you don't
mind folding up your chairs and just
putting them to the side you will make
our staff very happy thank you
[Music]